comment couper du métal avec de l'eau
des vidéos comme ça tu en as déjà vu
plein ça s'appelle le water jet le
concept est simple beaucoup d'eau qui
passe très vite par un tout petit trou
creusé dans un diamant ou un Ruby la
pression monte à 6480 bares l'eau sort à
plus de trois fois la vitesse du son
dans un fil très fin d'eau qui détruit
tout sur son passage pour augmenter la
puissance on ajoute du sable de grena au
liquide et on utilise un support spécial
pour que la table en dessous ne se fasse
pas pulvériser elle aussi c'est pas
juste marrant pour les vidéos YouTube
c'est super pratique il y a plus de 100
ans on utilisait déjà ce principe pour
creuser des galeries bon à l'époque
c'était pas très sûr mais maintenant
c'est beaucoup mieux moins risqué et
plus rapide que la découpe à chaud en
fonction de la taille et la force on
peut travailler sur d'autres sortes de
matériaux des enclumes aux pastèques
problème ça utilise beaucoup d'eau
écologiquement c'est pas fou en plus
certaines machines sont très peu
sécurisées ne mets surtout pas ta main
là-dedans maintenant que tu sais